deux fois par semaine paul saint germain
par de saint-hyacinthe avec son fils
charles pour se rendre à l'entraînement
de golf au collège de montréal
l'entraîneur du programme golf études
benoît lemieux connaissait les talents
du jeune joueur maskoutains il savait
aussi que charles était un autiste de
haut niveau capable de grandes prouesses
au golf n'est encore incapable il ya
deux ans d'attacher ses souliers tout
seul ou tout simplement de se moucher
malgré les retards scolaires de charles
benoit lemieux a accepté de l'entraîner
un défi au départ et un premier constat
charles est un joueur comme les autres
meilleurs même charles je ne conseille
une fois ci a compris ce que je voulais
dire il l'appelait qu'immédiatement
c'est ce qui m'impressionne c'est que
j'ai pas besoin de travailler très fort
sur plusieurs points différents os tout
que je lui ai dit il
il exécute très très ali la première
fois pour être honnête pour l'instant
j'ai pas vu du tout ça fait quelques
mois que je travaille avec charles
il fait les mêmes entraînements que tous
les joueurs il ya une belle
concentration une belle dynamique avec
les autres à 17 ans charles fait partie
des meilleurs golfeurs juniors de la
province après seulement cinq ans de
pratique quand on lui demande de nous
parler de son état d' autiste et de son
statut de golfeurs sa réponse est
directe et franche saint gobain une
maladie c'est plus un handicap genre ces
cheminements mais ça enlève pas ma
personnalité en tant que telle mais ce
que nous à l'école qui attend les
communes qui avaient clairement
chaque saison charles repousse ses
limites et améliore ses fiches ce qui
fait dire à son père que les parents
d'enfants autistes ne doivent pas
désespérer rien pas né les actions
comparé à voir je pensais de laisser la
chance au coureur puis d'être surtout
étaient impliqués l'enfant parfait pour
moi ça existe pondre sur les verts
charles se plaît à rêver de devenir à
golfeurs professionnels et de jouer un
jour comme son idole tiger woods
sa bonne voie pour genre sf à l'épée jim
et samatan ça arrive pas j'appelle
m'essayer gens devenus pros du québec
charles saint germain sera peut-être un
jour le tigre maskoutains en attendant
ils nous envoient tout un message
repousser le handicap dans un sport où
plus le handicap est petit est meilleur
on est bien frosi radio canada montréal
l'histoire de charles est bien sûr très
inspirante mais la réalité des personnes
et des familles qui vivent avec
l'autisme demeure un grand problème de
société un problème qui ne cesse de
croître le nombre de cas d'autisme est
en nette augmentation en amérique du
nord de 2002 à 2014 on signale une
augmentation de 123 % du nombre de cas
ce qui veut dire que l'autisme touche
maintenant un enfant sur 68